Bienvenue dans notre Institut.
Comme tu le sais, notre mission première
est d'accueillir et d'aider des individus
doués de certaines...
Capacités hors normes.
Les élèves de notre Institut ont d'énormes responsabilités.
Ils doivent lutter contre des mutants
animés de mauvaises intentions,
désamorcer des conflits internationaux,
bref, ils doivent sauver l'humanité
de la destruction et du chaos.
Te sens-tu prêt à relever le défi ?
C'est mon rêve depuis toujours d'intégrer
l'Institut.
As-tu un... Pouvoir spécial ?
Oui !
Dans ce cas...
Montre-moi ce dont tu es capable !
Voilà !
Je...
Je peux transformer les objets !
Hum.
C'est... C'est bien.
Par contre c'est...
C'est que en aubergine quoi...
Ah.
Ouais bon...
C'est oui le...
Le légume en question...
Et euh...
Uniquement le mardi...
matin.
Mardi matin.
Oui, d'accord, j'ai compris,
on va pas en parler pendant
mille ans...
Alors,
sois rassuré,
il y a quand même une place pour toi
dans l'Institut.
Super !
Tu vas aller
en 2B !
Aaah !
Hein ?
Euh... J'en ai encore un pour la 2B !
Ok, je viens le chercher...
Et y en a encore beaucoup à voir
aujourd'hui ou... ?
Booooonjouuuuur
2B !
D'aaaaaccooooord
Je suis capable de reproduire
parfaitement le son d'une flûte !
Pardon. Bonjour !
Ravi de vous rencontrer.
Tellemeeeeeent déçuuuuu...
Ah c'est bon c'est bon !
Hé, vous voyez quand même,
je sais faire des trucs hein !
Vite !
Dégage !
Je fermerai.
Bon bah moi je peux
traverser les murs !
Bon, ça marche pas avec
tous les murs.
Parce que moi j'ai essayé
chez moi sur du BA13,
Ça marchait bien,
mais après...
Non, attendez !
J'ai un autre pouvoir.
Je peux me métamorphoser.
Allez-y !
Hello !
Je suis...
LÀ !
Si, si si,
regardez bien !
Juste là !
Oui, voilà, coucou !
Hop,
hop,
et... HOP !
Hop là !
Hé, regardez, je peux
même descendre !
Hop là !
Ah merde !
J'ai jamais vraiment su
comment garder mes fringues mais....
C'est bien, nan ?
Est-ce qu'il resterait
de la place en 2B ?
Vite !